il ya des objections à la poursuite de
cette mesure sans objection le sénat
poursuivra la procédure le sénat
américain à majorité républicaine a
approuvé à l'unanimité le train de
sanctions contre la répression à hong
kong
républicains et démocrates sont donc
désireux de renforcer la position de
quelqu'un qui a promulgué mardi dernier
une loi sur la sécurité nationale dans
l'ex colonie britannique dans
l'hémicycle tous ont souligné ce jeudi
l'urgence de la situation à hong kong un
profond soutien à ce texte de sanctions
contre la chine qui arrive au lendemain
de son approbation par la chambre des
représentants contrôlée par les
démocrates
tfn hier nous avons adopté la loi hong
kong autonomie acte qui avait déjà été
adopté par le sénat et qui doit
contribuer à mettre fin à la campagne de
cruauté de la chine envers hong kong
vous m'avez entendu le dire encore et
encore si nous ne dénonçons pas les
violations des droits de l'homme en
chine en raison d'intérêts commerciaux
nous perdons toute autorité morale pour
dénoncer les violations des droits de
l'homme partout dans le monde
elle presse à newark la loi contre la
répression en kong devra encore être
promulgué par donald trump pour entrer
en vigueur
pour l'instant la maison blanche n'a pas
indiqué si le président comptait le
faire ou mettre son veto cette union
républicains démocrates montre en tout
quatre les parlementaires américains
pourrait être en mesure doute repasser
un veto présidentiel le cas échéant
cette future loi va bien plus loin que
les sanctions adoptée l'an dernier par
le congrès puis promulgué par le
président américain
objectif de ce nouveau texte visé non
seulement les responsables chinois mais
aussi la police de hong kong
des sanctions qui seront déclenchées
obligatoirement contre ceux qui
s'attaquent aux libertés promise au
peuple
hong kong et autre point crucial avec
cette loi washington pourrait
sanctionner les banques qui placerait
leurs bénéfices au dessus des droits
humains fondamentaux et des mesures
contre la chine qui alimente un peu plus
la colère de pékin
exhortons les états unis à bien
comprendre la situation à respecter le
droit international et les normes
fondamentales régissant les relations
internationales
washington doit cesser de s'immiscer
dans les affaires de hong kong de
quelques manières que ce soit ait stoppé
l'examen et la promotion du projet de
loi contre pékin sinon la chine prendra
certainement de fortes mesures en
réponse et toutes les conséquences
seront supportés par la partie avec avis
les sanctions américaines sont un
nouveau signe de l'aggravation des
tensions entre les etats-unis et la
chine
la loi sur la sécurité nationale
promulguée par le président chinois xi
jinping fait craindre à l'opposition au
congrès ce recul des libertés pour les
états unis comme pour d'autres pays
occidentaux royaume uni en tête
pékin cherche surtout à travers son
texte à museler l'opposition
après les manifestations monstres de
l'an dernier moins de 24 heures après
son entrée en vigueur la police
hongkongaise avait d'ailleurs procédé ce
mercredi à ses premières arrestations